I went and got my blood work done okay
and the reason I got my blood work done
is because I have really bad allergies
and I have really bad sleep patterns and
I have really bad
um like I have trouble breathing and
I've just been on this whole journey to
like figure out my health because for as
long as I can remember
I have bad sleep patterns
I have breathing issues like I've always
been
the type to like okay like I've done
sports right and we would have Fitness
tests and in the fitness test I would
run and another girl would run and I
would beat the girl usually by a lot but
I would be out of breath for like so
much longer like I would be like you
know